one very interesting video medium that i
experimented with
several years ago and which
unfortunately has recently gone
bust is called vu and it never really
took off the way that the
the designers intended it to do maybe
i'll talk about that
in another video long story short i have
a number of short two minute video
responses
that i created on vu to various vusers
as they were called at the time
and to other people including some of my
students who would submit these
questions
and just to put in a very quick you know
thumbnail sketch
the way that vu would work is you had a
video profile
and you would use your webcam and
you could you could write to other
people or they could write to you
somebody would write a question or a
comment and
and then you would address it in a
two-minute video
the resolution on a lot of these is is
not particularly good because you know
it was much older technology
and it had a lot of potential which
which largely went untapped i thought it
could be used for education
and i experimented with this pretty
extensively for
for a while before i started getting
much more into the
youtube videos so when they went
bust they gave us vusers the
backlog storage of
our videos and i thought it could be
kind of interesting
um to do a sort of best hits look at
some of the the video responses that i
made and try to you know
package them together and see if people
were
actually interested in this sort of
stuff so the clips that you're going to
see this is actually the first of the
videos that i'm
i'm going to stitch together of these
the clips that you're going to see are
all
two minute shorts and their responses to
people who had
either you know seen me on vu or had
been my students
or had read my one of my blogs and then
you know asked me a question about
something
and i'm gonna try to group them together
with with
more or less common themes they're kind
of all over the map
um but i don't wanna i don't wanna go on
too long i wanna actually get
right into these videos so with no
further ado
uh here's the videos
okay so here's a a question that can't
be answered in the time that's allotted
me on this but i'm going to give you an
answer
anyway how can knowing and understanding
philosophy enhance a person's way of
life
a million different ways if in fact you
really study real philosophy you're not
just studying some doctrinaire sort of
bs
or puttering around with a you know
single
problem that's very very specific but
actually reading
real philosophers thinking about them
meditating on their their works
talking with other people and gradually
making them part of your your mental
landscape
and also sort of companions on the way
for you
if you do that you've equipped yourself
to actually deal with a lot of problems
that other people are going to find
very puzzling may not even have the
vocabulary for can't recognize what's
going on
i can't tell you how many times having
been somebody who
specialized in moral philosophy and
philosophy of religion
and you know didn't get preoccupied with
with
just tiny little questions but actually
read broadly
in the field how many times that's been
useful to me
in my life or when giving advice
to other people in their lives family
friends colleagues
philosophy if you do it well it helps
you make sense out of things
and it never really does it as a whole
it lets you make sense of all the parts
and fit them together
bit by bit and make the right decisions
along the way that will also help you
make sense out of things progressively
so
this could uh you could write a whole
book on this
um so this is already in the too long
category for vu but i'm going to keep it
up here as it is
who's my favorite philosopher um
it's not an easy question to answer
because over time i've
come to realize that there's quite a few
different philosophers who i
love to read and to come back to
i
done most of my work on
four different people from four
different time periods
the one i've done the most work on
recently is saint anselm a medieval
philosopher and theologian
and i love working on him i love working
on
aristotle from the ancient period
i've published some things on thomas
hopps with whom i've got
what i would describe as a pornographic
fascination
you know you know you're not supposed to
uh
really like looking at the hobbs work
there must be something a little bit
wrong with you if you if you get into it
so much but i keep finding myself coming
back to it
and then maurice blondell from the
modern period a
french catholic philosopher kind of
underrated
whose work i've translated a bit of so
those are my favorite guys
but there's a lot of other people i like
to teach and to work on
i just some people are easy to teach but
not so easy to write about like plato
alright
so this is really a tough one and i have
uh
i've thought a lot about this one and
i'm not sure
i'll actually have an answer by the time
that i get to the end of this
um because you know at first i thought
well uh
aristotle or st thomas or somebody like
that but you know i think i don't want
somebody
who did so much systematic
work and sort of covered all the bases
so that would eliminate hegel as well or
maurice blondel
and i think
as i thought about it it's important if
i was going to interview somebody
that what they had to say would be of
interest not just to
philosophy types then it's not so much
of an interview it's more like you know
a conversation
and and more of interest to a general
audience
so i don't know i've seen interviews
with some of the great philosophers and
some of them are kind of
jackasses in interviews like uh you know
they're trying to make a point by by
being obscure or something like that so
i wouldn't interview le confer
for example um
and i bet you if you asked questions of
them
kierkegaard or nietzsche would probably
be like that
maybe who would be the most interesting
person to interview
would be a 20th century french
existentialist christian philosopher
whose name was gabriel marcel because
you look at the stuff that he says in
his writings and you look at the kind of
ethos that he that he projects
i think he would be a good person to to
interview i think a lot of people get a
lot of mileage out of what he has to say
so i can only pick one philosopher dead
or alive to have a chat with
um who would i most like to to do that
with
for me that's pretty simple and some of
of canterbury
i'm a saint anselm scholar and uh never
thought it would be
but i got drawn into researching him
because i
loved uh what i was finding in his
thought
so what's really interesting about saint
anselm is you have to do a lot of
philosophical detective work putting
things together from his letters
and treatises and prayers and
meditations and then the you know the
things that are left over like the day
simultaneous and the uh dicta and selmy
well in the life of saint ann's home too
and he what we know is that people
came to him because they found that he
had great answers for them and he could
explain things in in
great detail matching what he was saying
to the audience very very aptly
and he's not systematic in part because
he he rarely wrote things down unless he
had to
his letters are constrained by a
sort of requirement of brevity
he writes down quite a few of the things
that he does
only because his brethren impel him to
or because he thinks that people might
actually enjoy it he's not a scholastic
thinker who just writes and writes and
writes and writes
so i would love to have a chance to sit
down
and talk with him and press him on some
of the things that we don't really have
good answers to
so yeah there's my answer saint anselm
of canterbury
now that is a great question that's
really made me uh
think quite a bit um what i want to talk
to anselm
in his time in the
beginning of the high middle ages or
right after the norman conquest actually
or would i want to bring him into the
21st century
and show him around um
and you're saying i can't have both
because having both would be great i
mean both would have
amazing uh benefits i mean going back to
anselm's old time
own time and seeing him uh
say maybe at beck or at canterbury or
being with him in his exile
getting to talk with him just you know
about all these these different things
seeing how he used
metaphors uh to communicate to
everybody and watch him at work with
with the people of his time that would
be amazing
getting to sit at table talk with him
and the other monks and listening to him
discourse that would be amazing too
but i gotta say i think that i would
prefer to bring him
here into my own time and at first i i
was
thinking because of a sort of prideful
idea
it'd be nice to bring him here and get
him to talk about the sort of things
that i actually research and write about
and say ansel might have thought
this or he probably would have thought
this and some of my my uh
contemporaries say oh i don't think so
and maybe have him say
yeah actually this guy's right but
actually i would like to see
have him see and i think this would go
for a lot of other figures too like
aristotle or plato or thomas aquinas
or augustine i would love to have them
see
what our society is like what
technology is like and to reflect on
that and give me their thoughts on it
because these guys were just heavy
hitters when it came to thinking about
about things and reflecting and getting
at the the truth of matters
so i would love to bring him here
well uh yes and no i think
that you know here it would be best to
invoke something that
that aristotle uh brought up
there are things that are obvious
in themselves and then there are things
that are obvious to
specific people in specific cases at
specific times etc etc etc
and something can be obvious in itself
and you can realize it so afterwards but
you may in fact
have to overcome certain obstacles
only some of which are epistemological
uh some of which are
are actually moral
in well actually some of them could be
metaphysical too
in order to be able to grasp the
obviousness of them
you might say that that phenomenology
in large respect is the
philosophical practice of learning how
to strip away all the things that keep
us from being able to
to see the obvious for what it is and
in that sense you can say as you know
the great phenomenologists like you know
heidegger and
dietrich von hildenbrand and you know
there's one of those lines
required to have said about you know say
aristotle aristotle was doing
phenomenology just not calling
it such i don't agree that the
great philosophical discoveries are
things that are obvious
to the average person out on the street
i don't buy that
common sense is the be-all and end-all
and i don't think it means obvious in
the sense of like intuitively
obvious to everybody i think that that a
lot of cultivation a lot of work
a lot of preparation a lot of formation
is often required
for us to see what is in fact staring us
in the face
so hopefully that that's a good uh
answer in the sense of at least telling
you what it is
that i think about that
well you heard right i am in fact an
aristotelian of a
certain sort but um you know one of the
things i think you'll find if you
if you look at the people out there who
call themselves aristotelians
is that there's a lot of things that
aristotle thought
or you know was was quite sure about or
took a stand about or had some some sort
of argument about
that uh aristotelians for the most part
don't actually accept
aristotle was for slavery as were
if you look at it many other ancient
and also even medieval philosophers
he wasn't for sort of unrestricted
slavery and he would have been against
the sort of antebellum civil war
for you know pre-civil war uh slavery
that we we knew in the united states
that had such
terrible effects but that doesn't get
them completely off the hook
um aristotle also i mean if you want to
be quite um damning about this
aristotle also thought that women were
inferior to men
not just sociologically but but
biologically
he thought that non-greeks were inferior
as well
and probably couldn't be educated i mean
he had a lot of
viewpoints about things that there are
good reasons to reject
what's interesting about aristotelian
theory is that
if you if you look at it
the reasons for reasons for rejecting
some of aristotle's now to us quite
crazy views can be found within
aristotle's own work
and his own approach to things and if
aristotle were around today
and you sat him down at a bar he said
hey what about that woman thing
you know or that slave thing um you
would find him quite willing to change
his position because it would fit in
with the larger
matrix of his philosophy and his
understanding of human development
and relationships and moral values and
that sort of thing
so um this sounds actually like a very
good
dr sadler chalk and talk question as
well
can the aristotelian notion of a final
cause
or final causes i would i would actually
say or final causality
still be relevant today or as science
made it obsolete
i would say that in some of its
applications science made it obsolete a
long time ago
this is not any news leibniz was already
considering this question because it was
taken for granted by
most of the philosophers the
cutting-edge philosophers
already and you know in the early
enlightenment that
uh modern science just rendered you know
final cause is totally irrelevant
leibniz made a good argument for why
they still could be relevant
even in physics and biology and stuff
like that
and that's kind of interesting stuff i'm
not quite so
focused on that myself because i'm much
more
of a person who's focused on on ethics
and moral theory and political theory
than i am somebody who's focused on
philosophy of science or things like
that
um and within the human realm
final causality you can't make sense out
of human actions without
introducing some sort of similar concept
you can't see them as actually human
actions
without seeing them as intentional as
involving
ends and means and and you know even the
large-scale coherence of what
what somebody's up to depends on some
sort of notion of a final cause
does it necessarily have to be a final
cause
in an absolute sense like the one single
final cause
um not necessarily and i don't even
think that aristotle's necessarily
committed to that
but modern science doesn't really have
much to say about that sort of thing
those are two different vectors
okay so you're asking a lot of questions
and i suggest actually that you break
them up into several questions which
then i can answer
individually because vu only allows me a
certain amount of time and the last
several times i've tried recording this
i've run out of time
you're taking medieval philosophy this
semester is interesting
also very confusing that is completely
understandable i'm glad you're taking
medieval philosophy
because there are some really great
thinkers that you're encountering
and yeah it's going to be confusing
because you're you're
dealing with the conflux of ancient
philosophy
and christianity coming together and
people trying to make sense of all that
as well as ancient culture
you're also dealing with very different
ways of philosophizing than the sort of
thing that we
put forth as a model which is you know
really
in a lot of philosophy departments they
give a
very idiosyncratic if you look at it
historically very idiosyncratic
understanding to their their graduates
of what philosophy is
what do i think of boethius and abelard
i think they're both worth studying
personally i like boethius much more
than abelard in part because i am not
very attracted to what i consider kind
of empty scholasticism which i think
abelard
is a predecessor of i also
like his pridefulness
but i very much like his contemporary
and some of canterbury who i do a lot of
work on
boethius i love boethius i think that
um you should read him re-read them
re-re-read them
and uh think along with them uh
boethius has great passages
in in his works especially in the
consolation of philosophy you know
thinking about
what arguments are actually used for
they're not just used to convince people
they can actually
delight people i see that in anselm as
well and in thomas aquinas and in some
other medieval thinkers
oh running out of time
so as the pursuit of wisdom philosophy
raises questions about almost
everything does it question what it
means to question in the first place
yes and no um
philosophers some of the great
philosophers yes they've done that and
as a matter of fact i i know a lot of
unknown philosophers people that i've
been colleagues with
um people i've gotten to know over the
course of time
who do question what it means to
question in the first place but that's
because
they had the right kind of training i
think
there's a lot of ways of doing
philosophy these days where
they lose sight of that and they think
that questioning just means um
oh just trying to tear people down or be
skeptical
and they they never really deepen their
their questions and that's what
philosophy
is in part about and there were some
philosophers who actually talked about
this heidegger gets a lot of ground for
for bringing this up but he wasn't the
only one maurice blondell did
long before heidegger did mock schaeler
another contemporary of heidegger
uh actually uh discusses this sort of
thing as does dietrich von hildenbron
his student and they all realize that
yeah philosophy is is a reflexive
understanding of things gabriel marcel
as well great great
uh french thinker also um
you know they're they're concerned what
does it mean to question
in the first place and what does that
that mean and then it goes all the way
back to people like socrates
so all right that's enough for